this is a strip of Arizona highway five
years ago these rooftops are warehouses
then two years ago more warehouses and
here's that area today
on this 17-Mile stretch of road there
are now close to 40 warehouses with more
coming soon
this strip has become one of the fastest
growing markets for industrial real
estate in the country as companies look
to shift how they move Goods to avoid
supply chain bottlenecks but why are
companies picking this desert lined
Highway specifically
to my right would be the new Walmart
Distribution Center Amazon REI Dick's
Sporting Goods ups and more fill out
this strip known as Loop 303 which sits
about 20 miles west of Phoenix and
follows an arc that connects Interstate
10 to Interstate 17. but much of the
development is happening here between
I-10 and US-60 an area that was once
Farmland everything from cotton to you
know other types of feedstock were were
grown out here and over time the land
became increasingly valuable and so many
of these Farmers would sell to
Industrial developers or residential
developers and they'd come in and build
the kind of product you see today that
product massive Warehouse spaces like
this building that will soon be a
distribution center for sportswear brand
Puma we are trying you know to be
prepared for the future and therefore we
decided to go to Arizona and we will
build there a 1.1 million square foot
facility companies through the second
quarter had leased a net total of 16
million in square feet of industrial
space in the greater Phoenix area that
put it up there with Chicago and Dallas
Fort Worth as one of the country's
busiest sites for New Logistics activity
this year many of these buildings were
built before they even had a tenant
including Puma's future space developers
are confident that there are more
companies that want to locate along this
Corridor and they're saying we're going
to make a bet that this is going to pay
off if we build more warehouse space
another 19.8 million square feet of
industrial space is now under
construction in the Phoenix region which
includes the loop 303 corridor to see
why companies are doing this look about
300 miles west where there is a
bottleneck at the West Coast traditional
Freight Hub Southern California's Inland
Empire
many of the shipments from the ports of
Los Angeles and Long Beach stop here
after leaving the Docks but space here
is tight in the Inland Empire the
warehousing Market has a vacancy rate
that's Fallen below one percent so that
has forced companies that otherwise
would have been leasing space there to
look for Alternatives before picking the
303 Puma considered adding more space in
Torrance where it has its existing
Southern California facility but there
was a problem there is no space
available right now in Torrance and you
have to look into the future and I don't
expect it's getting better out there so
for Puma that meant looking East but not
too far east the company said about 95
of its product is imported from Asia so
it needed a facility that was still
within driving distance of the ports you
had six eight hours to the time in
transit you go overnight anyway so I
don't think it's a big deal Trucking
Goods over 350 miles to Phoenix versus
15 miles to Torrance can carry a cost
some companies and developers say
however that cheaper leasing rates along
the 303 make it more cost effective
overall that's especially true when the
consumer is in or near Phoenix Phoenix
for years has been a really a hotbed for
industrial growth but I think what's
namely different today is these Global
Brands these well-known consumer Brands
need to service the Southwest it's the
growth belt it's where people are moving
to Phoenix has a population of nearly 5
million and like other Sunbelt cities
it's been growing rapidly but it still
pales in comparison to the 24 million
person Market in Southern California the
reality is though many of these products
now are serving the Sun Belt so you know
they're bringing brought in whether it's
through the port of LA Long Beach into
Phoenix and now you can service West
Texas you know Colorado New Mexico
Nevada all from a central Hub you can be
either close to the port or close to the
customer so I think with the investment
in feelings we can actually serve you
know for a certain area of both so given
the advantages companies and developers
see in Phoenix some hope it'll be the
next Inland Empire but for now it still
has a long way to go what I Envision
over the next you know 30 to 40 years is
you're going to see a shift Westward
closer into California but still be in
Arizona and servicing the Southern
California Basin from here currently the
Inland Empire has one and a half times
the industrial space of the entire
Phoenix market and loop 303 is just one
part of that but this highway does still
have a role to play I think Loop 303 is
exactly the kind of solution companies
are looking for with the end goal of
helping all of us
get that little package on your doorstep
or pick up whatever it is at the store
that much quicker and faster and cheaper
[Music]